parlez-moi de vos femmes mais j'ai
tenu compagnie à un certain nombre de gentilles
dames c'est Brenda Wow elle n'a pas le
droit de porter de vêtements quand elle est trop
coquine non c'est une kleptomane
intelligente vous êtes entouré de gens qui se
soucient de votre journée que faites-vous  Je veux que
j'envie ta vie j'ai la tienne alors j'aimerais
avoir ta vie ni ces gars ne s'attendent
à changer de corps mais il y a une sorte
de coup cosmique fou qui se produit le
lendemain pouf je suis lui il est moi et nous
avons un problème
Mitch je  'm Dave we switch bonus the
writers of the hangover and the director
of wedding crashers est un excellent pedigree
pour exécuter une comédie un peu notée pour la
première fois de votre vie, vous êtes
beau, vous êtes à usage unique,
nous l'avons  Je vous
ai rencontré, vous deux, vous devriez sortir ce que
c'est incroyable parce que vous vivez dans un
monde où des choses fantastiques se
produisent, vous pouvez vraiment repousser les
limites de la comédie que j'ai eue
à 18 ans.
Je sais que c'est là  J'y vais juste ce
soir cambrioleur oh bonjour  ce concept n'est
pas quelque chose de nouveau, c'est quelque chose qui est
vraiment adopté par le public et je
pense que c'est bien mais ils l'ont
mis à jour ce qui peut
arriver de pire comme si vous prétendiez être un avocat
est-il complètement fou parce qu'il n'arrêtait pas de
citer des cas de droit & Order SVU Je m'objecte
oh mon dieu non c'était juste amusant de voir ce
genre de prémisse qui est généralement une
sorte de prémisse PG exécutée c'est un tel
avantage que nous ne le faisons pas de manière drôle et extrêmement
offensante c'est vraiment un
petit groupe spécial et amusant que nous avons  tu n'as pas de
relations sexuelles avec ma femme, [ __ ], tire-le à
l'heure oh mon dieu, ce n'est pas juste
des trucs dégoûtants arbitraires, je veux dire que ça a
vraiment fonctionné dans l'histoire et ce que
ces personnages traversent, tu
vois vraiment à quel point ces gars sont polarisés sur
toi vraiment  voyez à quel point ce serait dommageable si
une forme devait être dans la vie de l'autre fille
même pendant une courte période
Je pensais que vos enfants étaient adorables
mais ils ne sont pas pour les bananes Je m'en occupe
beaucoup avec les bébés dans ce  film je
ne peux pas faire ce truc de famille
Dieu oh arrête de pleurer c'est incroyable d'être dans
un film où tu n'as pas à
te retenir j'ai pleuré de rire c'est vraiment le
scénario le plus drôle que j'aie jamais lu
non non non non non
Je ne peux pas croire que tu viennes vers moi avec des
armes à feu